i will also think that we are going to
look back on these years of the iraq war
as a huge national mistake now we've had
leaders who have brought us into it but
the fact of the matter is that the
country ended up endorsing the iraq
invasion now it was bad information and
all of that but we agreed and we re
elected the president on it and I think
we are going to pay a price for 20 30 40
a whole generation it took us about 40
years to get out of the Vietnam syndrome
it's going to take us 40 years to
rebuild the military get out of the Iraq
syndrome and maybe at the end of those
40 years we'll have won back the world's
goodwill terrible tragedy